dear Edwards is a story that is born out
of this tragic circumstance
come here
we go
there's a deadly plane crash and the
only Survivor is a 12 year old child
named Edward who is my character's
nephew
what happened isn't fair Edward
I know I've never replaced your mom
Lacey wanted to have a child it's been a
struggle that's affected her marriage
her self-esteem everything and then
suddenly out of this tragic event
there's a boy who drops into her lap and
then her life starts to change and all
this really beautiful stuff happens the
airline will pay for a psychologist I
think it could be a good idea there's
this grief group community that comes
from other people who have experienced
this loss do you say a 12 year old boy
named Edward said the Edward are you the
aunt
yeah yeah that's me I guess I'm the ant
how's he doing
how are you doing
as disparate as the experiences are this
point of grief connects lives that would
never have known each other
Dede is someone who thinks that she's
got it all
with the death of her husband
gradually discovers none of it is real
he thought that he was going to turn
things around financially for you guys I
I know he was working on that
because the inciting incident of the
show is so tragic people might think
that it's going to be depressing but
really it is about watching people be
resilient
they find love they find connection it
reminds you of just how surprising life
can be
come anything if you have enough love
and support around you
in the face of grief the only way that
we go on is Hope
foreign
[Music]